all right biden's censorship uh
disinformation board what we call the
ministry of truth has been put on pause
his failed censorship czar resigned
after only through
uh three weeks on the job so just like
clockwork she goes right into msdnc to
let everybody know she's the victim here
really take a look
all these sensationalist narratives
about what the board was what people
thought the board was going to do are
completely wrong it was a coordinating
mechanism it was meant to you know make
sure that the very large agency that is
the department of homeland security that
people were talking to each other within
it it was really overwhelming chris i
mean frankly you know i have prided
myself over my career of being a really
nuanced uh reasonable person to say that
i'm just a partisan actor was was wildly
out of context and then beyond that it
wasn't just you know these
mischaracterizations of of my work but
it was death threats against my family
all right uh nobody supports a death
threat she herself said hunter biden's
laptop was disinformation she said it
was a trump campaign product that was a
lie she said it was a fairy tale about a
laptop repair shop that was a lie she
pushed the alpha bank russia conspiracy
theory that was a lie she said critical
race theory was a fake issue being
seized on by quote disinformers
she herself was the biggest purveyor of
misinformation and she went on the
biggest network of disinformation to say
she's innocent of disinformation here to
react to that much more there's a reason
we call him the great one he's the host
of life liberty levin on this news
channel every uh saturday night 8 p.m
i'm sorry sunday night 8 p.m
uh nationally syndicated radio host my
buddy mark levine great one i don't know
if you want to talk about her or if you
want to talk about the horrible
condition the country and the world is
in uh but i've never been more afraid
for the future of this country than i am
now and biden's not even been in there
18 months mark
first of all as for her
the nation will miss such a brilliant
articulate person
i don't know what we'll do without her
uh this this board they were trying to
set up sean is nothing new woodrow
wilson who was a racist segregationist
and of course a democrat
he set up something like this and i'm
sure joe biden would know something
about it because he's been all those
things through his career too
wilson issued executive order on april
13 1917 committing
creating a committee on public
information it was a massive propaganda
operation a massive censorship operation
but i i don't think we need her because
they have msnbc the new york times the
washington post cnn
and all the rest of the reprobate media
out there so i don't know why they
needed to be redundant with some
government committee that's number one
number two joe biden is a one-man
wrecking ball and he's taken his idiocy
to our economy and the american people
need to understand something and i've
said this before
you're living in the united states of
the democrat party they control all the
elected branches of government
you're seeing what it's like you're
seeing what their promises are like when
they're actually put into action
why is the southern border open
why is it open like this what is their
purpose obviously to import as many
democrats as they possibly can they
might backfire on them
but that's what they're doing why are
they spending the way they're spending
they're collapsing the economy with
inflation and so forth they were warned
about it and yet they tell us
the more they spend and the more debt
you have it actually fights inflation
joe biden is obviously an economic
illiterate always has been
but you can go down issue after issue
there are trashing of the united states
supreme court this is the democrat party
of america the attempt to nationalize
the voting system to ensure the
democrats always win oh that's a good
one
what else well what else do you need to
know baby formula
i mean what kind of advanced country
can't produce enough baby formula and he
blames it on whom the private sector
government regulations the fda shut down
abbott we weren't importing formula from
the european union which has stricter
standards than we do
and it's the private sector's fought
you're seeing power moving from the
private sector to the government this
guy's utterly incompetent can you
imagine
if rather than donald trump joe biden
had been president at the peak of this
virus
we wouldn't have had vaccines we
wouldn't have masks we wouldn't have
ventilators we would have respirators we
wouldn't have hospital beds we wouldn't
have anything
he'd be busy blaming the republicans for
the virus i mean he blamed trump for
every single death that occurred as a
result of the virus here's the bottom
line
this american marxism cannot work it
does not work these are people who've
never really done anything in the
private sector with their lives they
haven't created anything they haven't
built anything they live in their own
bubble this is a horrific ideology that
is alien to the united states and if
they had had
luck in passing that bill back better
nonsense we'd be in the whole another
five to six trillion dollars we'd be
facing a depression today and by the way
we're in a recession i don't care what
the economists say i see it we're in a
recession and if this is handled badly
we're going to be in a depression the
stock market has hit 1932 levels
interest rates are hitting soon double
digits
people cannot afford food and gasoline
in the united states of america we still
have supply chain problems six months
after they were identified in the united
states of america we had none of this
none of it when donald trump was
president of the united states vladimir
putin who is a monster has nothing to do
with any of this
it's not vladimir putin and his invasion
of ukraine it's biden and the democrats
and their invasion of washington d.c
and now we have threats against the
supreme court
threats to burn down the supreme court
violence against supreme court justices
this january 6 committee is a pathetic
joke we need a committee all right we
need a committee on what the democrat
party and their their mob has done 2020
during the summer their threats now
against the supreme court of the united
states how they ride it during donald
trump's inauguration we can go on and on
and on about these people that's the
fact as far as joe biden goes
we're going to have an election in
november
if we don't crush this opposition
if we don't win in 2024 america's gone
and the american people need to
understand something we can't win every
election but these people are playing
outside the box now these aren't policy
differences this is a choice about
whether you love america or hate america
you can't think of a single thing that
joe biden and the democrat party have
said that's positive about our founding
our founding documents our principals
and the american people all of us
red-blooded regardless of our color and
race they always put us down
that's it
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else